um life has changed wow it's so crazy
how I mean in in in amazing ways super
magical and also it's like
people react differently to me even
though I actually feel very much the
same you know I'm still the same artist
and like I still I think you should just
be nice to people like kindness is free
you should spread it everywhere guys um
agreed
yeah but it's it's been it's been a
journey but I love what I get to do how
did you like deal with rejection my bad
days on the couch watching runs of the
good fight Christine baransky soothes my
soul I don't know what that's about but
she's very calming I love eating carbs
and watching TV it's my favorite pastime
it really is I I just it makes me so
happy it's like I always know that's
available oh absolutely you've got you
everybody needs a comfort blanket ice
cream's mine carbs are yours I have
blankies too I baskets of blankies
everywhere I like I resort to like oh
yeah lus meets Carrie Bradshaw you
know and I heard you learned how to
reframe projection too yeah I mean my
first Big Brush was So You Think You Can
Dance but I was 18 I made the show and
then was very quickly
cut that was rough and I went home be
and I I you know had my own pity party
and went through a depression of sorts
because I
had deemed that failure and it took me
time like years to really understand
that that experience actually put me on
a different path it redirected me to New
York and New York is where I really
started to become an artist it's where I
had the opportunity to start over
because rejection I don't think should
should Define you your rejections you
can choose I choose to look at them as
redirections if that's not my room if if
that's not my door there's always
another door you got to knock like if I
you know Westside Story right if I had
not gotten over my own fears around you
know unworthiness or not feeling I was
Latina enough enough or that my Heritage
would be called into question and that
wouldn't be good enough for the masses
if IID let that keep me from walking in
the door we wouldn't be sitting here no
so not going in there and at least
trying is just not an option
[Music]
anymore